if you think this is new unusual
exceptional let me disabuse you what we
are experiencing is a visitation from
the past it is the new normal and it
will be the new future it's the last 40
or 50 years when we haven't had this
which is exceptional throughout history
there has always been vast tides of
History bath tides of people pushed
ahead of
Excellence famine War 7 million in
displaced people's camps after the
second world war the Flotsam and Jetson
washed up where they were left absorbed
into their societies
it's now come back to revisit us and it
will be about our future too because if
you think the tide of humanity now
knocking on our door is
is big wait until global warming takes
effect not long ago I was in Kuala
Lumpur talking to the asean Nations who
are already seeing and beginning to plan
for the four million people who will be
displaced after the sea levels rise by a
meter which they're reliably predicted
to be going to do
they're dealing with that as a region
and that brings me to my second Point
there's no way that you can deal with
this except in a European context this
is our region you have to have a
europe-wide policy and therefore I
believe our government's policy towards
this is both morally questionable and
extremely stupid because we can't even
deal with the three thousand knocking on
the dates that Gates of the channel
tunnel if we do not deal with the
migrations moving into Europe their
solution is also ours and instead of
resting on our side of the 20-mile wide
moat that separates us from this by the
way probably a 50th as wide as the
Mediterranean which people aren't having
difficulties getting across instead of
sneering of the Amer that the rest of
our Europeans feckless Bunch are having
difficulties coping with a million when
we weren't even constantly concentrate
our mind on three thousand we should be
joining them in the end they will
stumblingly get there at least they are
trying they will find the means to deal
with this crisis and that brings me to
my third point I think that this is
about the future this is a new
geopolitical fact of our life and in the
end we're going to have to find the
policies to deal with it I have a
suspicion that in the next five to ten
years there will be an International
Conference that draws up new rules new
regulations good heavens we might even
have to revisit the definition of an
asylum Seeker we will definitely have to
visit we will definitely have to visit
until that's two minutes and I have
three we will definitely have to visit
we'll definitely have to visit how we
separate the hangers on the piggybackers
from the genuine Asylum Seekers and I
suspect we're going to have to find a
new definition for those who are neither
Asylum Seekers nor economic migrants but
have had their homes taken away from
them by global warming in the course of
that we will give great opportunities
for those who some of us don't like to
sing the devil's songs it will be a
battle for Humanity against those which
we might lose unless we're very careful
but if you do lose it then I am no doubt
whatsoever that you will add refugees to
the already numerous reasons why wars
exist on our planet of which I believe
and you may do so too that we already
have an over sufficiency
thank you
thank you very much
thank you next up is an advisor on
migration and human rights at the United
Nations there at the high Commission on
human rights for her perspective Pia
oberoi thank you thank you very much I
just wanted to reflect a bit on
migration because it is the empowerment
of a young woman able to earn a living
for the first time in her life it is the
hope that a community places in a young
man sent abroad to provide a Lifeline
for those back home it is the story of
innovation and Entrepreneurship of
migrants the ideas and the knowledge
that they bring and those that they take
back home with them but today as Paddy
has pointed out the predominant story of
migration is one of exclusion and
inequality refugees forcefully violent
conflict and persecution migrants
compelled to escape what the United
Nations Secretary General has called
Silent crises grinding poverty
environment and destruction hunger the
desperate precarious mass movements that
we are seeing today are by no means
truly voluntary and juxtaposing
deserving against undeserving human
beings ignores a complex reality
too many people are being forced to
leave their homes and communities in
search of security and dignity most of
them are not in Europe nor are they
coming here but Europe cannot any longer
remain aloof from the global crisis of
Mobility
many European countries are in
demographic decline with aging
populations and a shrinking Workforce
Europe desperately needs more young
people to run its Health Services
contribute to the tax base and look
after its elderly because increasingly
Europe societies are no longer
self-sustaining and overwhelmingly
migrants are not looking for charity at
the same time local populations deserve
a more accurate picture of migration and
not a series of Badly Drawn caricatures
for sure there are few easy answers but
the solution to the chaos and suffering
we see at land and sea borders
lies in governing migration
intelligently and compassionately not
embarking on futile efforts to prevent
it at all costs
the universal principles that bring us
together as human beings must surely be
the basis on which responses to the
current migration crisis should be built
governing migration fairly means
upholding legal obligations to respect
the human rights of all migrants and
refugees acknowledging the real needs of
Labor markets particularly in the care
economy and low-skilled job sectors and
crafting entry systems that protect our
values as well as our borders migration
policy must be premised on evidence and
compassion not on misperceptions stigma
and fear
thank you
thank you next uh to give his
perspective uh is the speaker who joins
us from Hungary where he is the director
of research at the sizzled vague
Foundation it's a conservative think
tank which is the official advisor to
the Hungarian government on this subject
on matters of migration so with his
opening perspective uh balash Orban
foreign
thank you very much for the invitation
first of all I have to start with the
clarification although I came from
Hungary and my family name is Orban and
I we are the official advisors of the
current Hungarian government I'm not a
relative of the of our Hungarian prime
minister so it's just a coincidence but
I I've wrote some thesis sentences for
you
um I think we Europeans are responsible
for the current stage of the migration
crisis Auto migration is a neuter
expression some shape of migration is
positive and some is negative the
humanitarian assistance is an obligation
of all the countries around the world
although it doesn't mean that we have to
receive everybody as a refugee and it
means that that the form of a
humanitarian assistant assistance cannot
be formalized or standardized
so I think the mass flow of people
is right now we have a special form of
migration so we hungarians we call it we
have a special Hungarian expression it's
called that population migration so it's
a mass flow of migration there is no
English expression like this I haven't
found it so maybe you're aware in that
so we it's a special form of migration
what we have uh now and this special
form of migration is a serious problem
for all the EU member states and need to
be stopped because we Europeans lost
control
control means I'm teaching
constitutional law so control means
sovereignty Europe last lost sovereignty
in this situation and if we do not take
immediate action the current crisis will
threaten most of our commonly shared
values as you are heard about the
uh that the threatening of the EU as an
area without internal borders which is
already threatened and I think that
first of all we should
make two steps we should accept or agree
on a package first part of the package
is that our politicians
the the body language of the of our
politicians need to be changed the
external communication of our about the
language uh of the body language of the
uh politicians need to be changed and
secondly our legal system right now it's
catalyzing or galvanizing the whole
process so we have to change the legal
system why am I saying this because just
imagine the situation that you are in
Afghanistan you were in Bangladesh or
you were in Africa you
you don't have to chance to start a new
life in the European Union legally so
you will never get a visa to arrive to
Europe and start a new life there it
doesn't matter whether you are a refugee
or a migrant the only chance you have is
the is to move on from your country of
origin walk around the continent not
cooperate with the transit countries
arrive your receiving country and there
apply for an asylum and if your Asylum
is granted then you will have the chance
to stay in that country legally if not
then you will send it back I think it's
nonsense and this is anti-human this
current process so we have to stop that
we have to regain our sovereignty and
then we can talk about migration and
then the refugee issues as well thank
you okay
just just I just want to clarify one
thing there you said about it having to
stop does that mean your advice to the
government of Hungary when it comes to
the number of refugees or migrants who
should be allowed in is is your advice
that figure should be zero
no well it's a different from the
problem is that what we were facing in
Hungary that we can we are not capable
of registering the people because there
is a massive flow of people so first of
all we have to change the uh the the
whole
um legal system and legal regime and
then we can regain control and make a
decision whether somebody is Refugee and
somebody is an economic migrant and
that's the second question what we think
about immigration so but that's a
different situation we are confusing
things all right let's go to uh our
fourth uh speaker known to many of you
here uh leading British politician who
held the roles both of Defense secretary
and foreign secretary serving in the
governments of Margaret Thatcher and
then John Major and maintaining a close
interest uh in foreign affairs uh with
his perspective on this question Sir
Malcolm Rifkin
thank you very much let me begin if I
may by responding to one of the
questions that Jonathan asked as the
grandson of a migrant I have no
difficulty saying that migrants can very
often make a very viable contribution to
the country that that receives them that
is uh very straightforward I want to
concentrate my opening remarks on the
question of Asylum Seekers and the
current crisis which involved not
hundreds or even tens of thousands but
millions of people who are entitled to
think of themselves as refugees seeking
Asylum some of the facts are not
controversial it is not controversial
that people have a right under
international law to seek Asylum if they
are being persecuted secondly it's not
in dispute there are several million
people mostly Assyrians but not just
syrians who can claim that entitlement
at the present time
and I think thirdly also I have no
problem with the proposition that the
United Kingdom and Europe must accept a
share of the obligation to meet that
requirement but let me move into
slightly more controversial therapy
the first point I would make is that the
vast majority of the Syrian Asylum
Seekers are no longer in Syria there are
many who are in Syria but I'm talking
about the two or three million perhaps
even more than that who are mainly in
turkey or Jordan or Lebanon and at this
moment in time they are no longer
suffering uh persecution that has made
them Asylum Seekers they have Asylum
although not in very agreeable or
attractive circumstances and with no
certainty as to their long-term future
but they are not currently a risk to
their lives because of the government
and the country from which they have
left second point
people have rights of seeking Asylum
they neither have nor have ever had a
right to say and I want to go to this
particular country and it's unreasonable
and unacceptable for that country not to
accept me there is no such legal
entitlement that is a matter for both a
receiving country and the Asylum Seeker
to reach agreement on and thirdly there
is no specific British or european
obligation that doesn't apply to the
rest of the world
the treaty obligations we all operate
under are Universal obligations and
therefore if there are millions of
people seeking Asylum this is not as
it's so often described a challenge to
Europe it is an ethical and legal
obligation for all the Civilized
countries of the world to share in
responding to this burden and the final
point I would make in these opening
comments is in addition to that there is
a very real question as to whether the
best way when you're dealing with
millions of people who are living very
close to their original country
many of whom will want to return to that
country most of whom are actually of
these refugees are exactly the sort of
people their own country needs even more
than the rest of the world because of
their professional skills and their
other educated qualities we have to also
look at ways of allowing them to remain
as close as possible to Syria which will
require billions billions of pounds or
dollars of help from the International
Community but and also a change in the
rules that at the moment prevents them
even being able to work when you're
living as a refugee and an asylum Seeker
that is absurd and obviously it causes
maximum discontent so there are a remedy
of solutions but I conclude by saying it
is not either ethically or legally
correct to imply that there is a
uniquely British obligation or european
obligation all the past problems such as
at the end of the second world war led
to millions of people going not just a
year elsewhere in Europe but to the
United States to South America to
Australia and in the case of Arab
refugees the Arab states themselves many
of whom are incredibly wealthy should be
accepting their share of the obligation
also okay
let me um
before we hear from our last week I just
wanted to follow up one just one thought
there about it's about partly about
terminology those people who have fled
Syria but are now in the neighboring
states as you've described uh whether
Jordan 11 or turkey what's the right way
to describe those people should they no
longer be described as refugees because
they are no longer in an urgent
situation of seeking Refuge how would
you describe there are refugees because
they have not yet got a any country
including turkey Lebanon and Jordan that
have given them permanent rate of
residence that is why under the stupid
rules at the moment they're not even
allowed to work but you want to
distinguish between those and the person
fleeing Syria for their life I am simply
saying that they are not at the if you
are in a refugee camp in Turkey Lebanon
or Jordan it's a pretty unpleasant
experience but it is not one okay that
means you continue to be a threat to
your life the things that made you a
refugee in the first I understand I just
wonder if there's a way in the language
where we could have a word that
distinguishes those two situations but
maybe we just don't have it let's hear
this our last speaker with some opening
thoughts and then we're going to
obviously uh get into discussion uh the
fifth perspective on this question comes
from the rabbi of new North London
synagogue and the senior Rabbi of the
Missouri strand of Judaism in Brittany
lectures widely writes widely and with
his perspective on this question please
welcome Rabbi Jonathan Wittenberg
let me begin with uh with a human
obligation I was in Calais at the camp
there with a range of interfaith leaders
and I was rather worried that we would
be tourists of disaster but people
wanted their stories to be heard and a
man from Sudan he called me over to his
tent which I wouldn't even call a
two-person tent and he had sleeping bags
and blankets it was very cold in there
two people could just about squeeze in
and since then the weather has become
cold and it's it's it's wet and it's
it's raining and his situation reminded
me that by the age of 16 both my parents
were refugees from Nazi Germany so this
is an issue very close to home and moral
home in the Jewish Community though not
that alone in particular and my father
when I was 16 took me aside one day and
he said Just remember do your schoolwork
because you can take everything from a
person accept what's in their mind
and what struck me actually about these
refugees he once said I'm I'm a medic
I'm a computer scientist is actually
their minds have been taken or the
capacity to to use them have been taken
from them as well and from the point of
view of human compassion there is an
obligation of of collective of
collective care how that pans out among
countries is is is a secondary and a
clearly important question and there's
very widespread Goodwill I've got at
least four ngos operating or being led
from my own community
so that's about compassion then there's
a question about what's Equitable and
intelligent
uh one couldn't from the point of view
of Jewish history not have in mind as
they've been European conferences about
who will take whom and how many and the
disagreements have in mind the Evian
conference called by President Roosevelt
and his wife Eleanor in France in the
summer of 1938 at which
not only did virtually no country say
they would take a greater number of
people fleeing Nazi fascism it actually
allowed Goebbels to say in Germany well
they complained that we don't like the
Jews but they don't want them either
which led almost directly to the
escalation of violence against them so
there is an obligation seems to mind to
be to find an equitable way of sharing
across Humanity the care for what is a
part of our own family
the last thing I want to talk about is
long term and this was already said
before I'm very nervous that the
terrible events in Paris eight days nine
ten days ago
will eclipse the coming events of the
climate conference in Paris but it's
very clear that the less of the world's
service is habitable
the greater will be the number of
refugees and therefore we need to act
the best we can against both Warfare and
environmental degradation in the
long-term interests of having as much of
the Earth livable home to people as
possible
thank you
we've we've had the um there's sort of
opening perspectives let's just as I
said get into some sort of Freer and
open discussion I'm just going to pick
up with something with you balesh and
then I would like others to come in on
this
um your governance position anyway was
um and you know in September several
countries voted against uh the move that
would have uh seen refugees allocated as
it were uh across Europe in late
September there was an agreement that
120 000 refugees would be if you like
distributed across the European Union
four countries voted against the Czech
Republic Hungary Romania and Slovakia
who does hungry imagine
will take in these immigrants these
refugees rather if hungry worked I mean
what is the there'll be plenty of
countries that think it's difficult to
take in refugees if each country says
well we don't want them who who does
your government and other governments
imagine will take them in Staten
economic problem the the problem is that
they don't want to stay in Hungary
they want to go to Germany and to Sweden
and because they want to go there
because they are invited so that's
what's happening and welcome perhaps and
well actually I think the situation is
changing rapidly but but used to be
welcomed for sure
um I would like to talk about uh and we
cannot do anything against that we we
also have Hungary we also have
humanitarian obligations we are
participating in a unhcr relocation
programs so we welcome refugees directly
from Syria the same as what Great
Britain is doing right now so but that's
another story what's going on right now
uh I want to talk about shortly I
suppose what I'm saying is you know they
can't live in Syria because it's become
uninhabitable that country because of
the war so where should these people
live do you think they should live in
their neighboring countries
um I just was a bit confused by by
Malcolm if you forgive me because he's
usually so very clear he rightly
differentiated between those who are in
fear of their lives or Genuine Asylum
Seekers are desperate and losing their
own lives and losing the lives of their
children fleeing across the oceans and
the dusty and rainy muddy roads of the
Balkans to get to us and those who are
living perfectly safely in camps not
comfortably but safely who are not
Asylum Seekers who are indeed close to
the country where the Apparently Malcolm
wants them to be so if that's the case
what is the logic for the government to
say it will only help those who are not
in desperation in the camps and refuses
to take part in the European program to
help those who are genuinely desperate
and Asylum Seekers is it the word Europe
that sticks in your group
okay find my answer if you just the
government is helping those who don't
need help in preference to those who
desperately by your own definition yeah
if you let me answer there's a very
straightforward reason for making the
distinction I think one of the most
unwise consequences of Angela merkel's
offer to dig eight hundred thousand is
it has not only
fueled the existing movement it has
encouraged literally millions of people
who perfectly rationally would prefer to
live because of the prosperity of Europe
in Germany or other European countries
it has encouraged millions of people not
just from Syria from North Africa as
well and from Somalia from Eritrea and
from I could give a dozen other
countries to say well as long as we can
get to Europe we can because there are
countries that are willing to take us
and therefore there's a difference
between people fleeing from Syria in a
dangerous way crossing the water and
risking their lives that I have total
Sympathy for the people hold on people
who are no longer in Syria who are
living safely in Turkey if they choose
to cross Dangerous Waters risking their
lives they are doing so because they
prefer to live in Germany than to live
in Turkey no I don't criticize them for
doing that that's what they wish to do
but they do not create an obligation on
the countries of Europe to take every
one of the millions of people who may
make that okay
thank you Paddy Paddy Paddy before you
before you come back because I want to
make sure there's other people here in
that situation though Malcolm if they
have been made the crossing and it's
dangerous and they're in the water and
rescued where then should the let's say
it's an Italian ship that rescues them
or a Greek ship where then should they
be taken I I accept we are now Fierce
for the de facto situation we have to
make sure that these numbers are not
swelled by further hundreds of thousands
which is exactly what will be happening
as we speak if we do not reach agreement
not only as to how we are going to give
Refuge to those who are in Europe but
how we are going to have simultaneously
a policy that says so far and no further
okay I know Penny wants to get in but I
want to hear other people peer
um this idea that we heard balash
articulate that actually the right place
for those people is in the surrounding
states what's your counter what's your
reply to that should is the right place
for these people Lebanon pretty
stretched I know but Lebanon and Jordan
Turkey Etc the average time person
spends and displacement or Refugee
spends into space
into space that's just the average time
we have people that are born and bred
and grow up in refugee camps the syrians
that have been sitting in say in Jordan
Lebanon and and then moved on to Turkey
um have not been able to access the bare
minimum of of of subsistence for
themselves we have talked to people that
have moved on because they haven't found
education decent education for their
Children Healthcare and I think this
really speaks to the the beginnings of
the refugee regime the refugee regime
was crafted in 1951. it was crafted at a
time in a place where persecution was
the reason for movement civil and
political rights were privileged over
economic social and cultural rights the
idea of somebody moving because they saw
no future for themselves they saw no
future for their family was was somehow
put in a second tier but what we are
seeing now is precisely people saying
that that's not the way that we can live
our lives we don't have the right to
work in Turkey in Jordan we have no
education for our children and no health
care so in a sense this is what you're
seeing you're seeing the culmination of
a governance system that is in desperate
need of fixing John Jonathan Wittenberg
the the thing have you spoken a kind of
moral language about this subject would
Britain say discharge its moral
responsibility to those people uh who
have made it out of Syria but are in the
neighboring state by funding them to
have a more comfortable life in a
refugee camp in Jordan or Lebanon or is
the moral obligation the only moral
thing to do to actually welcome them
into this country this Society of ours
there seems to me there is a question
about Justice and about what is
Equitable I can't see how a long-term
solution is going to be accepted across
the world when some of the poorest
countries are expected to take the
greatest burden and therefore both in
terms of supporting refugees who've
arrived at bordering countries and in
accepting appropriate numbers I know
there's going to be discussion as to
whether one can Define that or not would
be part of a country's obligation in my
view could I comment on that on that
exact point yeah I think part of the
answer to your question is that a
country like turkey or Jordan or Lebanon
needs not to be expected to fund giving
a proper standard of living to the
refugees in their midst in they need and
deserve billions of pounds dollars Euros
from the wealthier countries so let's
say that enable them to do that okay so
Hungary you said balesh that you
wouldn't want them coming in there but
you thought the places they should be in
is those neighboring states would hungry
write the check to make it easier for
Lebanon and those other places to
receive the refugees that you wouldn't
want actually in Hungary yeah well
actually we are doing that and we are
supporting the hot spots outside the EU
so so from outside the EU they have the
right to apply for an asylum that's a
humanitarian obligation also but but we
are enforcing we are encouraging them to
to March through Europe it's it's
actually ridiculous and we are not only
talking about uh syrians because that's
a very different uh very special case
because of the politi uh because of the
military conflict we are talking about
Africans uh uh Bangladesh people from
coming from Bangladesh Afghanistan
Pakistan so these these countries are
are bee hives of instability and poverty
and economic conflict what we should do
with those people that's millions and
millions of people should we allow them
to enter the European Union without any
control I don't think so we have every
every developed country on Earth has a
humanitarian obligation to have those uh
those people somehow but it doesn't mean
that that we have we need to have them
like immigrants